it's no secret that the loud house is
one of our favorite shows but have you
ever seen different versions of these
popular Nickelodeon characters
wait until you see Laurie as a
bodybuilder and what Lily would look
like when she's older don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out the ten loud house characters
reimagined by fans Luna loud the 15 year
old Luna loud has to be one of our
favorite characters so let's start with
her she's everyone's favorite but have
you ever wondered what she'd look like
with a slightly different look for
example an 80s look a deviantART user
the fresh Knight did an amazing job on
this one check out the 80s Luna typical
80s mullet paired up with her usual
purple colors doesn't she look awesome
she's already humming plenty of 80s
tunes so we can definitely see her
fitting into the world and considering
rock and roll was completely wild in the
80s
she'd be an even bigger wild child and
she is now Lennie loud the 16 year old
Lennie is the second oldest loud
character she fills the big sister shoes
when Laurie's too busy with her
boyfriend Lenny's extremely cheerful and
sometimes she might be a little bit
naive but that's what makes her
personality so special master oh yeah
from deviantART did an amazing job just
reimagining Lennie as an anime character
doesn't she fit right into the anime
world long blonde hair large blue eyes
always happy and excited it's definitely
the Lenny loud we know and love this
illustration gives Lenny a
two-dimensional version she deserves to
have and of course the amazing white
sunglasses are there - LuAnn loud
speaking of favorite characters how
could you not love the fourteen-year-old
LuAnn and her crazy puns the loud house
world would not be the same without this
hilarious character but what if we made
LuAnn even crazier jfm Studios from
deviantART reimagined LuAnn is a
completely crazy character dressed in
her signature yellow outfit it looks
like Lynne is ready to put up a fight
with some nunchucks an intruder land
style the nunchucks come in the shape of
a chicken we can't even imagine what
she'd do with those but it's a pretty
hilarious sight to see we bet she'd call
them nun chicks instead clyde mcbride we
talk a lot about the loud
on this show but the focus is hardly
ever on the adorable Clyde and his
amazing family as Lincoln's BFF Clyde
has a tough job of entering the loud
house world and keeping his crush on
Laurie under control don't worry we
totally get it buddy
I lose ninety-one art from tumblr
reimagined Clyde is a girl and we're
totally here for this adorable photo
check it out
curly hair earrings and a blue bow we
bet her name would be Claudia although
that would mean her last name would no
longer rhyme still just adorable though
Lola loud we've often compared Lola loud
- honey boo boo they're almost the same
person if you think about it this six
year old cartoon diva is equally as
crazy and she absolutely loves pageants
but what do young princesses grow up to
be they become queens JCM - from
deviantART reimagined Lola as the queen
of diamonds the artist made her look
older and almost turned her into a
brand-new character she looks absolutely
incredible
of course she's still wearing her iconic
princess crown and definitely got that
improved and her pink outfit is equally
as impressive we are totally here for
that cave
Lisa loud the four-year-old Lisa is
truly a special character not only is
she crazy smart she's also pretty funny
when she wants to be her signature look
is a green sweater and some regular
pants or her lab coat when she's working
on her stuff the art tricks from
deviantART reimagined an older version
of Lisa and we have to say this looks
like it's pretty spot-on we have no idea
how old she is but it looks like she
still has the same glasses in the same
well not so happy look on her face after
all this is Lisa we're talking about
Lucy loud it's extremely hard to pick
favorite characters on this show but
Lucy is definitely one of them she might
be only eight but her soul appears to be
so much older than that jfm Studios on
deviantART beautifully reimagined what
Lucy would look like with some pretty
awesome superpowers the author noted
that this version of Lucy can throw a
little ghosts out of her hands and these
ghosts are totally on fire if that's not
a superpower that would suit Lucy we're
not sure what is it really does make you
wonder if this fire ever goes away or if
it's always in her hands glory loud of
course we have to talk about the oldest
loud child in the
family the seventeen-year-old lorry
might seem a bit annoyed at her siblings
but she also stands up for them when
she's not bossing them around we found
one of the most hilarious fan art
pictures ever bruiser punch from
deviantART reimagined Laurie as a
bodybuilder and she looks absolutely
hilarious she definitely had way too
many protein shakes but on the good side
she can probably go after just about
anyone that would mess up with her
siblings but it looks like she can't
text with her phone in her hand
Lincoln loud then comes the 11 year old
Lincoln the main character and the one
who this entire show revolves around
Lincoln is extremely caring to all of
his siblings and he seems to understand
whatever's going on but what if he
turned just a little bit mean be Center
prices on deviantart reimagine Lincoln
as a character from a game called
sonic.exe doesn't he look scary we have
a feeling this version of Lincoln
wouldn't be as appealing to the crowd
especially since his dark eyes are just
incredibly weird imagine seeing a
character like this on a show like a
loud house Lily loud since the 15 month
old Lily is so young she doesn't really
have a specific personality like the
rest of her siblings we do know that she
loves spending time in the Lincoln but
that's about it
we'll have to wait and see how this kid
will grow up but luckily talented fans
have sped up the process Anton dis from
deviantART Illustrated what an older
Lily would look like isn't she adorable
she pretty much looks like a younger
version of Lenny we absolutely adore her
light purple outfit as well as her
blonde hair what kind of personality do
you think Lily would have make sure to
let us know in the comments and that's
all for our video thanks for watching
we'll see you next time
[Music]